[Musique]
bienvenue dans la semaine dans le monde
sur France 24 on fait le tour des une
internationales de la semaine avec nos
éditorialistes j'ai le plaisir d'avoir
cette semaine avec moi Marianne meunier
bonsoir journaliste à La Croix bienvenue
la Une de La Croix aujourd'hui c'est
l'Iran l'art au coeur de la révolte on
voit donc le journal tout à fait
d'actualité et puis vous avez également
le magazine dont la une c'est sur le
metaves vous saurez tout sur le métaver
j'imagine en lisant donc le magazine de
la Croix bienvenue Marianne en face de
vous Laure Simos bonsoir Laure
directrice éditorielle de Cartooning for
Peace bienvenue Patricia limoniat avec
nous grands reporter bonsoir Patricia
Marx ces mots aux collaborateur au
journal Le Monde est avec nous ce soir
Bonsoir à vous Marc avec au sommaire
l'Ukraine dans le noir après les
bombardements russes qui visent les
infrastructures coupures d'électricité
coupure d'eau courante le Parlement
européen a voté cette semaine une
résolution qualifiant la Russie d'État
terroriste alors que les mercenaires
Wagner sont maintenant accusés
d'exactions dans un rapport
lire en réprime tous azimut dans la
région kurde du pays notamment mais
aussi en bombardant les Kurdes d'Irak la
Commission des droits de l'homme de
l'ONU a déclenché une enquête les femmes
arrêtées sont violées étaient errant
étant passe de ce doter de l'arme
nucléaire
en France l'Assemblée nationale à voté
en faveur de l'inscription de l'IVG dans
la Constitution la proposition de loi
des insoumis et donc soutenu par la
majorité même s'il reste encore un long
chemin avant une modification de la
Constitution
et puis en Chine à zenzu Foxconn a
finalement présenté ses excuses après
les protestations qui ont donné lieu à
des affrontements avec les forces de
sécurité plus de 20 000 employés vont
quitter leur poste au sein de la plus
grande usine d'assemblage d'iPhone au
monde politique zéro covidoblige leur
ville vient d'être confinées
et on va démarrer par l'actualité en
Ukraine après ces bombardements massifs
russes qui visent maintenant toujours
les infrastructures qui est la capitale
et sous le coup de coupure d'électricité
de coupure d'eau courante le Parlement
européen je vous le disais à voter une
résolution qui qualifie maintenant la
Russie d'État terroriste les mercenaires
de Wagner sont également accusés cette
semaine d'exaction dans un rapport au
live en Wagner on va écouter tout de
suite volodi mire Zelinski
la terreur énergétique est comparable à
l'utilisation d'armes de destruction
massive avec des températures en dessous
de zéro
plusieurs millions de gens sont
fournitures d'énergie
sans chauffage et sans eau
il s'agit évidemment d'un crime contre
l'humanité
le peuple c'est ce qu'a dit Emmanuel
Macron Marc stratégie russe c'est une
stratégie explicite le MS par ailleurs
l'organisation mondiale de la santé mais
on garde sur de possibles millions de
morts que pourraient créer cette
situation
à cause de l'hiver froid etc alors
ensuite bon
parti peut-être exagéré mais il y a
cette réalité et le commandant de
l'opération spéciale le nouveau Sergueï
seront sous Vikings a été à bonne école
c'est lui qui commandait les opérations
en Syrie et c'est en partie exactement
la même politique qui est celle de
briser toutes les infrastructures
civiles alors là c'est surtout les
infrastructures électriques mais bientôt
se pourrait être aussi les hôpitaux pour
casser le moral de la population et
l'amener à d'une certaine façon en avoir
assez de la guerre et faire pression sur
on en met pas là parce que dans la phase
actuelle ça galvanise plutôt
on l'avait vu avec connu trois ans
quatre ans de siège il y avait aussi les
coupures il y avait pas d'électricité
les gens montaient 20 étages à pied dans
les tours voilà ce qu'il faut voir c'est
qu'on en est maintenant au 9e mois de
guerre elle est pas prête de s'arrêter
elle était prévue la logique de Poutine
pour durer trois jours dans ces 9 mois
de guerre les
Ukrainiens ont déjà récupéré la moitié
des territoires qui avaient été occupés
par les Russes après le 24 février ce
qui est déjà énorme mais il reste quand
même 20% de l'Ukraine qui est tout
occupé par les forces russes ou par des
rebelles
séparatistes donc voilà on ne voilà ça
sera un long hiver de guerre qui va être
terrible et on s'installe dans une d'un
conflit qui semble destiné à durer et
donc l'Ukraine dans le noir Patricia ça
va que Carson on vient d'apprendre qu'il
y a 15 morts là enfin c'est en tout cas
d'une source gouvernementale locale
est-ce qu'ils ont des difficultés sur le
terrain les Ukrainiens on se pose à
quelle question parce que le front ne
bouge pas beaucoup oui enfin d'abord il
pense qu'il se remettent de quand même
parce que hackerson les Russes sont
partis mais avant il y a eu ils ont ils
ont avancé ils ont perdu beaucoup de
monde et donc c'était quand même
douloureux pour l'armée ukrainienne
Carson donc dans un premier temps on se
reconstitue comment les Russes
aujourd'hui frappent sur Carson deux
évidences moi je suis pas dans le secret
des militaires mais il y a déjà deux
évidences qu'on peut voir on sait que
Vladimir Poutine est quand même aux
commandes et à une vue directe sur
l'armée et donc là je crois qu'il y a un
simple désir de faire payer à cette
population ce qui est apparaît comme une
défaite quand même sur même pour
Vladimir Poutine et donc de se venger
purement et simplement et puis aussi il
y a aussi la crainte que parce qu'on dit
ça ne bouge pas sur Carson mais si il y
a des mouvements qui se passent au sud
de la péninsule et plus au nord sur le
Nièvre et là ce que les Russes craignent
c'est qu'ils essayent de passer par ces
deux côtés au sud et au nord pour
finalement avancer en direction de la
Crimée et donc c'est les bloquer c'est
les immobiliser dans la poche de Kerson
en continuant à taper sur cette ville et
effectivement on a vu aujourd'hui je
crois que l'hôpital a été évacué parce
que il est pour les habitants ça va
devenir à mon avis de plus en plus
infernal que de vivre dans dans cette
cité et je reprends un tout petit mot de
ce que a dit Marc parce que je partage
son analyse mais je crois que Vladimir
Poutine est encore dans il se restreint
actuellement parce que en Syrie il a
d'abord tapé sur les infrastructures et
après il est allé sur les civils les
hôpitaux les écoles et cetera là il y a
une ou deux maternités qui ont été tapés
mais c'est l'état l'étape après et là
j'espère qu'ils n'ont pas jusque là
désespéré le peuple Marianne en tout cas
c'est effectivement ce qu'a dit Emmanuel
Macron et c'est plutôt bien exprimé
alors le Parlement européen est allé
encore plus loin puisque dans une
résolution votée cette semaine ils ont
parlé d'un état terroriste pour
qualifier la Russie et Fabienne Keller
qui était d'ailleurs sur ce plateau nous
disait que c'était pour finalement
mettre en place un arsenal juridique
donc là on va très loin symbolique pour
le moment parce que c'est arsenal
juridique n'existe pas donc pour
l'instant ça peut être une première
étape mais si un jour il est écrit il
faudrait quand même il faudrait quand
même beaucoup d'années donc
c'est le moins que le simplement
européen pouvait faire mais c'est aussi
le plus qu'il peut faire aujourd'hui moi
je voulais revenir sur cette terreur
énergétique de la Russie sur l'Ukraine
je pense que c'est aussi l'occasion une
nouvelle occasion pour le peuple
ukrainien et pour volo durelinski de
démontrer la résistance de sa population
je pense notamment à la mise en place de
ces centres d'invincibilité tels qu'ils
sont appelés donc il y en a 4000 en
Ukraine ou dans lesquels la population
pourra se réfugier en cas de coupure
généralisée où il y aura de centres
chauffés Internet etc et en fait encore
une fois la communication est très
importante côté ukrainien dans dans
cette situation de de mise à l'épreuve
par par la Russie les informations
nationales et puis bien sûr toujours la
propagande de Vladimir Poutine on va
l'écouter il a rencontré aujourd'hui le
président russe les maires de soldats
déployés des barres de soldats justement
déployées en Ukraine et puis de
également de russe mobilisée vers de ses
fils c'est la première chaque fois qu'il
les rencontrait on va l'écouter
il est évident que tout est beaucoup
plus complexe que ce que montre les
télévisions et Internet rien n'est
fiable
il y a beaucoup de fausses informations
de mensonges qui circulent
auprès d'elle c'est la première fois
qu'il les voyait c'est vrai qu'elle
mette un peu dans l'embarras le pouvoir
c'est maire de ces mères d'enfants qui
envoyaient à la guerre sur le fait le
bilan alors le bilan reconnu
officiellement par les Russes je crois
qu'il est autour de 15 villes je me
souviens plus combien c'est mais la
plupart des experts étrangers notamment
les Américains qui ont quand même des
satellites qui
évoque entre mort et blessé donc soldat
ou de combat 100.000 personnes ce qui
est énorme la guerre d'Afghanistan
c'était 15000 donc
Parlement européen qualifiant la Russie
des terroristes c'est très ambivalent
vous remarquerez que nibiden le Biden
président américain
on ne traite pas avec or là-dessus on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a quelque chose qui
risque aussi de peser son avenir c'est
cette prise de conscience de plus en
plus des opinions publiques et des
députés européens qui l'expriment parce
que c'était un vote massif 494 voix
contre même pas une quarantaine veut
condamner clairement voilà la Russie le
poids de ces mots est énorme alors
ensuite bon le point de vue législatif
le traduire en ordre juridique bon il y
aura des des procédures que vont être
ouvertes au niveau de la justice
internationale un jour ou l'autre mais
il y a quand même une portée symbolique
énorme
de ce mot mais ce mot est un terroriste
au niveau des opinions publiques au
niveau donc de ce que représente le
Parlement européen engage il faut voir
je pense que si on en est pas que là
dans la terreur c'est qu'une phase dans
la terreur qu'est-ce qu'on va trouver
après pour condamner aussi parce que
faut faire très attention je vais faire
dans l'échelle on va déjà très loin on
va déjà très très loin parce que la
situation est dramatique mais Vladimir
Poutine peut aller encore plus loin
alors qu'est-ce qu'on va faire Emmanuel
Macron lui dit Patricia et Marianne
qu'il va avoir un contact direct avec
Vladimir Poutine alors est-ce que ça
veut dire dans les prochains jours alors
qu'est-ce qui peut sortir d'un contact
direct entre Emmanuel Macron et Vladimir
Poutine Marianne
pour le coup il maintient toujours sa
position c'est la position classique du
président français je parle aux deux
pour le jour où mais je veux dire le
jour où sur le terrain c'est le problème
c'est qu'on ne voit pas Vladimir Poutine
en l'état bougie on le voit dans son
discours il veut gagner dit-il donc
c'est-à-dire qu'il n'a rien à offrir
dans une solution de paix et on voit la
stratégie ukrainienne qui à mon avis de
mettre pression sur la Crimée mais dans
à mon avis en arrière-plan l'idée de
négocier parce que si je fais une
pression sur la Crimée peut-être que ça
sera une pierre que je pourrais échanger
contre une autre pierre qui est Dombasle
négocier les Ukrainiens alors
qu'effectivement finalement c'est
bombardements ont plutôt attisé leur
patriotisme
tout quand même pour les la négocier les
Américains disent le chef d'état-major
américain a dit publiquement aucune des
deux parties ne peut gagner cette guerre
militairement donc c'est donc y compris
les ukrainiens et donc cela veut dire
qu'il faudra trouver d'autres ce qu'il
faut qu'il leur faudra trouver d'autres
solutions donc venant de Washington
c'est quand même un message lourd les
Américains font aussi clairement
comprendre des contenus à ne pas livrer
toutes les armes que demande des
Ukrainiens
qui permettraient justement d'attaquer
directement la crise avec un risque
d'escalade majeur vu le symbole que
représente la crinée la Crimée pour les
Russes donc on est quand même dans une
logique actuellement où il y a peut-être
un moment où il pourrait y avoir
pas une paix mais disons un
refroidissement des choses ou à cesser
le feu mais on en est encore loin mais
juste un point c'est que le problème va
se poser au printemps parce que les
Américains vont être obligés pour livrer
certaines armes qui livrent aujourd'hui
de plonger de prendre dans leur stock
stratégique et ça les militaires ne
veulent pas en entendre parler donc
c'est pour ça que les militaires
poussent à la paix pas parce qu'il croit
à la paix parce qu'ils veulent pas qu'on
leur prenne leurs armes les dessinateurs
qu'en disent-ils
un premier dessin justement du
dessinateur ukrainien Vladimir
casanovski qu'on montre très
régulièrement sur sur ce plateau sur
cette nouvelle maternité qui a été
bombardée donc dans la région de
zapouridja avec un bébé tué ce qui est
assez saisissant dans ce dessin c'est le
contraste entre l'image de la douceur à
gauche et puis l'extrême violence à
droite et puis j'en profite pour vous
dire parce que c'est quand même
important que Vladimir casanovski va
bientôt venir à Paris le centre culturel
ukrainien lui consacre une exposition à
Paris et puis cartooning for peace du
coup profite de l'occasion pour
organiser une table ronde à la Fondation
Jean Jaurès le 6 le 6 décembre à 19h
avec notamment et en partenariat avec
France media monde puisque Elena
Volochine votre concert va y participer
et que Pierre Aski aussi c'était une
parenthèse c'était une parenthèse parce
que vous êtes partenaire évidemment et
puis parce que Vladimir casanovski c'est
quand même l'un des plus grands
dessinateurs de presse Ukrainiens
un autre dessin tout aussi puissant du
dessinateur suisse Chapatte qui est
aussi très bien trouvé Poutine en fin de
trouver un général compétent l'hiver
faites le souffrir dipotine c'est
intéressant parce qu'on voit toute la
cruauté évidemment du personnage mais
aussi sa solitude et son isolement c'est
intéressant à regarder cette autre
dessin du dessinateur français Yas qui
est aussi très touchant ce portrait
d'une grand-mère ukrainienne qui se
prépare du coup à vivre dans le froid et
dans le noir et ce qui est aussi très
saisissant dans ce dessin c'est là aussi
le contraste entre l'humanité à l'excès
la grand-mère la figure de la grand-mère
et puis l'inhumanité évidemment de cette
guerre et puis pour terminer avec un peu
d'humour noir à la soulsier ce dessin
pour l'Est Républicain le Black Friday
puisque c'est aujourd'hui c'est tous les
jours en depuis que les Russes bombarde
nos installations
kurde du pays notamment mais aussi en
bombardant les Kurdes de Dirac la
Commission des droits de l'homme de
l'ONU a déclenché une enquête les femmes
arrêtées sont violées selon plusieurs
témoignages et selon là aussi des
enquêtes Téhéran et en plus en phase de
ce doter de l'arme nucléaire on va
écouter Emmanuel Macron
les petits enfants de la Révolution font
une révolution et sont en train de la
dévorer ce qui est le plus
impressionnant dans ce mouvement cette
révolution c'est que ce sont des jeunes
femmes et des jeunes hommes qui n'ont
jamais vécu que sous ce régime
c'est ça ce qui est très impressionnant
il a changé un peu de discours vis-à-vis
de l'Iran on va en parler mais avant ça
on va parler de la Une de La Croix donc
un l'Iran l'art au cœur de la révolte
donc vous vous intéressez à ceux qui
résiste sur place bien sûr alors que la
répression est de pire en pire on va le
voir mais oui effectivement on a
constaté qu'il y avait un foisonnement
de création artistique qui sont à la
fois inspirés de la révolte et qui en
même temps la nourrice puisque elle l'a
représente et c'est une manière de
d'encourager en fait en fait les
manifestants et les artistes sont comme
les manifestants ils prennent un grand
nombre un grand nombre de risques à
s'impliquer il y a d'ailleurs des
arrestations régulières
cinéastes
l'auteur de l'hymne qui est devenu
célèbre Barry a été arrêté pendant
quelques temps récemment c'était un
rappeur il y a eu des documentaristes le
week-end dernier donc les artistes qui
sont impliqués ils payent aussi le paye
aussi le prix fort dans dans ce
soulèvement que eux-mêmes d'ailleurs
appelle révolution exactement il appelle
une solution Patricia alors il y a eu
ces frappes ce sera intéressant de
parler des Kurdes quand même ce soir
parce que manifestement dans le
Kurdistan iranien ça ressemble à une
scène de guerre civile entre les tanks
les hélicoptères de guerre enfin
franchement on est passé encore à une
autre échelle et puis il y a eu des
frappes en plus dans le Kurdistan
irakien cette semaine donc là on sent
qu'il y a une répression tout azimut
effectivement le Kurdistan de toute
façon
il y a un autre région qui est sunnite
et qui est qui est de l'autre côté mais
le cordistan est toujours aidé à bête
noire à un des désiraniens il y a eu des
révoltes qui ont été tout au début de la
Révolution sauvagement réprimé là ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'en plus il
déploie les Gardiens de la Révolution
elle dépend la force elle coûte ce qui
qui ne s'était pas déployée avec char et
tout toute l'armada et donc là c'est la
force elle coûte est connue pour quand
elle intervient elle intervient
sérieusement donc c'est une armée qui se
déploie qui tire etc et là cette armée
qui tire contre la population kurde tire
aussi effectivement au Kurdistan irakien
parce que le kurdistère à qui on le sait
a depuis longtemps pris en refuge les
cures de Iraniens qui s'étaient réfugiés
chez eux et qui n'avait plus d'activités
militaires mais que les Iraniens
accusent de commettre effectivement
alors c'est ça il les accusent
finalement d'être à l'origine de la
révolution les soutenir alors c'est
facile
c'est approuvé le tout c'est que
qu'est-ce qui va se passer c'est très
rare qu'on l'Iran attaque un pays
étranger c'est pas dans la tradition
iranienne c'est plutôt je suis encerclé
et je riposte sur ma table attaquer
c'est pas dans la démarche dans la
mentalité radienne là ils attaquent mes
attaques parce qu'ils pensent que en
fait l'Irak c'est un peu l'Iran
l'Irak étant à la botte le gouvernement
doit absolument mettre ce petit peuple
irakien kurde une seule chose c'est
qu'il y a des accords en Irak et que les
Kurdes sont autonomes mais ça pour eux
c'est pas un problème en tout cas la
France on voit que Emmanuel Macron a
changé de discours parce qu'on l'avait
vu avec le président iranien à l'ONU à
New York savais d'ailleurs beaucoup été
décrié par les Iraniens qui sont dans la
rue et là tout d'un coup on voit qu'il
reçoit des opposantes iraniennes qu'il a
un discours vraiment sur la répression
en tant que tel en train de se passer
change totalement la donne notamment au
niveau international par rapport à
l'Iran parce que bon d'une part la
répression a changé de nature justement
dans les zones qui sont pas c'est pas
Téhéran c'est justement c'est Kurdistan
sont des gens de minorité ce sont des
zones sunnites mais c'est aussi de
manière de la part des Iraniens de dire
regarder
de notre territoire est en jeu mais un
autre élément qui joue énormément c'est
la question de l'accord sur le nucléaire
parce qu'au début y compris l'opposition
était pour arriver à relancer l'accord
sur le nucléaire aujourd'hui la plupart
des opposants disent non on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui la communauté internationale
ne peut pas combien même ce serait
possible d'y arriver on en est loin
l'Iran annoncé qu'il enrichissait
maintenant enfin l'Iran n'a pas annoncé
la IEA l'agence pour énergie
sur le chemin
donc le l'Iran évidemment ne veut pas
relancer l'accord mais quand bien même
ça serait possible ils disent non on ne
peut pas aujourd'hui passer un accord
avec un régime qui tire sur son propre
peuple on ne peut pas aujourd'hui faire
un tel accord parce que l'argent qui
pourrait re-entrer dans les caisses de
l'Iran ça serait de l'argent qui
servirait à la répression donc on est
rentré dans quelque chose qui est
beaucoup plus compliqué de voir sur cet
accord
d'une révolte à est-ce que c'est déjà
une révolution on ne sait pas encore
mais il y a quand même tous les éléments
qui peuvent laisser penser que c'est une
révolution ensuite comme dans toutes des
révolutions pour le moment on ne voit
pas qu'est-ce qui pourrait remplacer
pour l'instant le régime est toujours là
le régime est plus répressifs en 2009
c'était encore à l'intérieur du régime
on espérait une victoire des réformes
qui avaient été privé d'une élection
présidentielle manipulée en 2019 c'était
une révolte de Gueux donc assez
périphérique sur laquelle d'ailleurs les
les on a tiré beaucoup plus on était à
1900 morts on était à
19300 mais voilà là on a toujours 78
morts c'est une autre dimension sont les
forces vives du pays les artistes la
jeunesse urbaine les étudiants toujours
pas les secteurs économiques le bazar
commence dans le bazar commence à se
mobiliser à fermer il y a des grèves
donc il y a quand même quelque chose
contre bouger Marianne mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a des
jusqu'au-boutistes des deux côtés
c'est-à-dire du côté du régime vous
parlez de fuite en avant et je pense que
c'est exactement ça mais aussi peut-être
du côté des manifestants les les
artistes ou les Iraniens avec laquelle
lesquels j'ai pu parler ce qui n'est ce
qui n'est pas facile contenu de du fait
que le régime bloque ou ralenti
considérablement internet disent qu'ils
n'ont plus rien à perdre et et en ce
moment on s'attaque au tabou à des
tabous qui jusqu'à lors résister tous
les sens si vous avez vu des vidéos de
de ces gens qui sont assez tragiques
comiques d'ailleurs de ces gens qui dans
la rue font vaciller les turbans les
religieux c'est extrêmement symbolique
en fait c'est c'est le symbole de la
chute du régime qu'ils aspirent de leurs
vœux et puis la maison de probabilité
et ça c'est quand même inédit et puis on
a cette photo justement peut-être qu'on
va la voir de ces deux amoureux elle
s'envoient en train de s'embrasser à
côté d'une voiture on l'a montré pendant
la semaine parce qu'elle a beaucoup
aussi tourné sur les réseaux sociaux et
là aussi on s'attaque au tabou on voit
bien enfin franchement donc
mais ce qu'il y a c'est qu'effectivement
il y a plus vraiment de réformateurs en
Iran c'est ça en fait que vous dise
cette population iranienne oui les
réformateurs c'est nous qui avons cru ce
sont décrédibilisés manifestement on a
cru que le régime était avait des
réformateurs en son sein non il avait
des gens qui étaient plus souple que les
durs j'ai envie de dire mais il n'y
avait personne qui voulait changer le
régime arrêt formateur c'est celui qui
veut le faire
évoluer ce qu'il y a ce qui a cassé le
truc en dirant ce qui a vraiment cassé
cette Trump aussi c'est à dire qu'on a
arrêté cet accord en le jetant il a jeté
ces fameux réformateurs dehors c'est à
dire que ces réformateurs avaient
suscité moi j'étais là à ce moment-là
avait suscité un tel espoir il y avait
la jeunesse qui attendait tellement et
puis là plus rien
mais ça c'est dans la logique
la responsabilité américaine de plus en
plus
ne cachait pas sa volonté de faire la
pression
avec deux éléments nouveaux donc d'un
côté le risque d'un scénario à la
syrienne
et en plus l'Iran était comme le grand
dernier
du régime de Bachar el-Assad donc la
répression de tous ces émeutes avec
l'autre scénario qui est aussi celui
monter en puissance des Gardiens de la
révolution en tant que France politique
il contrôle déjà un énorme pouvoir
économique et d'une d'un régime qui
passerait d'une théocratie alors il y a
encore un guide à lui ramener voilà mais
de plus en plus avec cette idée que
finalement il n'y aurait plus peut-être
plus de guide mais il y aurait un espèce
de pouvoir
qui ferait des concessions en revanche
sur un certain nombre de trucs religieux
type le foulard etc pour un peu faire
baisser la pression mais qui serait
encore plus nationaliste encore plus
déstabilisant pour toute la région
répressif et répressif évidemment c'est
encore ouvert mais pour l'instant la
répression est extrêmement forte les
dessinateurs
néerlandais tir de Royat ce qui traduit
bien une forme d'impasse dans lequel ce
pays se trouve mais en fait plus la
répression pour tenter de faire barrage
et forte et plus le torrent de
manifestant en fait est aussi fort et et
augmente donc d'une certaine façon le
régime d'emmola est déjà un un petit peu
acculé un autre dessin du grand
dessinateur iranien mana neyestany voilà
sur justement au Kurdistan iranien une
répression qui qui conduit le régime à
carrément aller jusqu'à bombardé les
cures de Iraniens qui sont exilés en
Irak honnêtement je crois que il était
temps que l'ONU commence à déclencher
une enquête quand même sur sur cette
répression et puis pour terminer on en
parlait tout à l'heure un dessin de deux
camps sur ces manifestants qui
effectivement font tomber le tueur des
mots là il rend fin de régime pour les
mots là ben oui c'est c'est peut-être le
symbole d'une fin de règne en tout cas
on sent qu'il y a quelque chose d'un
point de bascule ça c'est c'est
actualités en France cette semaine avec
l'Assemblée nationale qui a voté en
faveur de l'inscription de l'IVG dans la
Constitution la proposition de loi des
insoumis a donc été soutenu par la
majorité on va écouter mathildeplanot la
chef des insoumis à l'Assemblée
nationale
cette émotion elle est ressentie par
toutes et tous aujourd'hui parce que je
crois que avec ce vote l'Assemblée
nationale parle au monde notre pays la
France parle au monde et envoie un
signal magnifique à l'ensemble des
femmes de notre pays mais aussi à
l'ensemble des femmes du monde Patricia
alors ils n'ont cessé en fait de
comparer la France avec les États-Unis
la régression américaine pourrait
arriver en France c'était ça un peu tout
l'argument alors qu'il faut rappeler que
86% des Français sont favorables à l'IVG
mais c'est une bonne idée de la mettre
dans la Constitution alors moi je vais
pas me prononcer parce que je connais
pas trop en tout cas dans le passé dans
le principe il y a effectivement un
risque qu'on ne sait on ne peut pas
prévoir ce qui va se passer dans 20 à 30
ans 10 ans 5 ans on ne peut pas prévoir
si des parties politiques situées sur un
échiquier qui réclame et qui sont très
frileux vis-à-vis de l'IVG et bien ne
voudrait pas revenir sur la loi veille
c'est très difficile de revenir sur la
loi veille mais c'est encore aussi
difficile de faire passer
cette réforme dans la Constitution on
aurait fendu
c'était un long cheminement et on ne
réforme pas la Constitution française
comme ça il y a plusieurs possibilités
ou un référendum ou le votant en congrès
au avec les deux chambres faut-il encore
que le président se saisisse de la
question oui le chemin va être long ce
qui est là la majorité il y a favorable
sur le texte commun et peut-être que
justement il y avoir une proposition un
projet de loi donc gouvernementale il
faut voir ce qui va se passer au Sénat
maintenant Mariam c'est vrai que le ce
projet fait l'objet d'une rare Concorde
quand même dans à l'Assemblée nationale
quand on y pense le projet a été
approuvé par des députés de la nupesse
mais aussi par des députés du
rassemblement national il y en a une
quarantaine me semble-t-il
Marine Le Pen c'est abstenu notamment
une quarantaine qui ont voté pour donc
en fait est-ce qu'il y a une urgence à
inscrire ce projet dans la Constitution
quand on voit que en en fait la
population française comme l'hémicycle
et favorable à l'avortement
est-ce que est-ce qu'il y a un réel
risque effectivement l'avenir on peut
prédire l'avenir
par exemple voilà les politiques de
manipès il vous répondent mais justement
il faut utiliser le fait qu'aujourd'hui
ça passe voilà maintenant au cas où il y
a une régression
ensuite ce qui est intéressant c'est que
dans le texte projet de loi c'est
garanti l'effectivité et le droit égal à
l'IVG parce que la vraie question n'est
pas tant l'interdiction de l'IVG parce
qu'on imagine mal surtout maintenant
aucun pays européen même pas on a vu les
régressions en Pologne en Hongrie
en Italie ce qui est intéressant
la politique de ces gouvernements et de
le rendre de plus en plus dans les fêtes
quasi impossible c'est-à-dire avec les
médecins objecteurs dont toute la
Lombardie vous ne trouvez plus quasiment
une clinique vous pouvez avorter etc etc
etc et donc par rapport à ça le fait de
mettre dans la constitution de la
garantie de l'effectivité de la loive
c'est une manière aussi d'éviter le
contournement c'est-à-dire non pas
l'interdiction plus récente de diviser
mais le fait de le rendre à faisable
mais là il y a un vrai enjeu de santé
publique dont il faut pas faire
l'économie et peut-être que ce débat sur
la constitutionnalisation à un peu
occulté ça et effectivement l'enjeu
c'est l'information sur l'avortement et
l'accès à l'avortement dans les
notamment dans les dans les déserts
médicaux donc il faut pas que parce que
ça va peut-être être inscrit dans la
Constitution on se lave les mains de la
dimension très pratique en fait ce qui
se passe sur le terrain
en France parler de déserts médicaux un
référendum ou pas il faudrait
Patricia ça c'est la question bon alors
avec justement avec un projet de loi il
y aura pas besoin de référendum il
faudra 3/5 des voix au Congrès c'est à
dire à son ménage et Sénat réunis le
problème du référendum c'est que c'est
plus les très souvent ce n'est pas sur
le sujet que les Français se prononcent
c'est sur l'homme qui propose le
référendum et là si vous voulez les
hommes politiques n'ont pas ne sont pas
très chaud parce qu'en fait et ça
détourne vraiment aussi le le sujet
parce que si un jour on devait se
prononcer sur le sur l'IVG et qu'il faut
en fait se prononcer sur Emmanuel Macron
on laisse tomber complètement la
problématique de l'IVG donc il y a dans
le référendum Quand tu es dans un pays
aussi clivé que la France aujourd'hui
quelque chose qui me chagrine donc
effectivement
la réunion du Congrès est plus
satisfaisante je crains aussi qu'un
référendum donne la voix à des positions
qui sont assez minoritaires et pour
autant très inflammable les politiques
exactement donc effectivement je suis
pas sûr que ce soit le bon choix donc on
attend ce projet de loi et manifestement
projet de loi qui pourrait être voté de
manière
[Musique]
aussi tout le monde aura compris
évidemment l'allusion sur le fait que
cette semaine quand même on traitait en
même temps à l'Assemblée le sujet de la
corrida avec le sujet de l'IVG c'était
pas le meilleur tempo je dis ça je dis
rien troisième et dernier dessin
toujours très bien vu de notre
dessinateur
urbs qui restent tout de même prudent
mais toujours marrant l'avortement dans
la Constitution enfin attendre avec le
délai qui aurait encore on a le temps
d'accoucher donc c'est pas gagné
en Chine Foxton la plus grande usine
d'assemblage d'iPhone au monde a
finalement présenté ses excuses après
les protestations qui ont donné lieu
cette semaine à des affrontements avec
leur force de sécurité on apprend tout
de même que plus de 20 000 employés ont
quitté leur poste les manifestations ont
continué ce vendredi et malgré ses
protestations et bien le confinement
sanitaire de 6 millions de personnes
dans cette ville à démarrer et sachez
que plus du tiers de la population
chinoise et maintenant confinée
justement à cause de cette politique
zéro on va écouter le porte-parole de la
Commission nationale de la santé
nous devons adhérer au principe suivant
les gens d'abord la vie d'abord nous
voulons freiner le nombre de cas
importés et le nombre de
recontaminations au niveau national nous
maintenons la politique zéro covid mais
enfin pourquoi alors une balle dans le
pied c'est une impasse alors ce qui est
intéressant Antoine Flahaut qui est un
des grands épidémiologistes faisaient
une analyse pour montrer que au stricte
point de vue sanitaire la politique du
Zéro covid menée par la Chine donc
depuis le début de la pandémie à marcher
de fait c'est le pays qui a le plus le
plus faible mortalité par habitant mais
en même temps cette politique
est un fiasco total qui les condamne à
une impasse parce que aujourd'hui non
seulement il y a les confinements
répétition alors il y a un tiers du pays
qui est plus ou moins confinement il y a
une ville comme shenzu où on a vu ce qui
s'est passé ensuite il y a des
conséquences économiques énormes
c'est-à-dire bon Apple fait 70% de ses
téléphones à 5 jours mais Apple déjà
j'ai commencé il y a deux trois ans et
maintenant ça va s'accélérer
ils ont commencé à se déplacer en Inde à
faire des accords avec l'Inde pour
installer les voilà et la vraie histoire
c'est que la Chine
obsession de la politique du Zéro covid
a totalement raté la politique de
vaccination avec un vaccin national qui
en plus est peu efficace contre le micro
et qui a été beaucoup exporté au Brésil
me souviens au tout début ils ne veulent
pas pour des raisons de fierté nationale
prendre comme tout le monde du Pfizer ou
les produits équivalents donc c'est une
totale impasse pour leur économie
effectivement c'est plutôt pas bon du
tout puisqu'on est plutôt en train de
parler d'un taux de croissance vers les
quatre pour cent on voit que les usines
il y en a plein qui ferment enfin en
tout cas elle fonctionne au ralenti et
là ils sont en train de mettre sous
cloche encore l'ensemble du pays oui
effectivement en fait sur tous les plans
de la politique zéro covid ne fonctionne
pas c'est-à-dire que elle n'empêche pas
une augmentation des cas 30 000 par jour
30000 ce qui est vraiment peu pour la
Chine mais ce qui est
il a quand même quelqu'un qui peut faire
sauter si un jour il décide c'est son
ministre de la Santé qui est une
redoutable ministre et qui quand elle
arrive dans une ville tout le monde est
au garde à vous elle est capable de des
pires décisions pour la population donc
il a quand même son joker j'ai envie de
dire mais au-delà de ça au-delà de ce
qu'on vient de dire la crise économique
l'échec des vaccins ils viennent de
sortir un vaccin vous avez vu par la
bouche qui apparemment émerveilleux et
qui devrait régler tous les problèmes on
va voir mais moi ce qui me marque le
plus aujourd'hui c'est ces jeunes c'est
ces gens qui
osent défier ce régime à ce point-là
quand on sait la force qu'à un régime
chinois quand il vous dit quand vous
traversez pas dans la rue vous allez
peut-être perdre des points de la plus
avoir de logement ce contrôle qu'il a en
général sur la population et là on voit
cette population qui lui échappe qui
craque craque qui lui échappe alors il
n'est pas on ne conteste pas encore le
Grand Timonier mais la population lui
échappe et envoie à l'ambassade de
France a fait je sais pas
l'ambassade de France qui a
diplomatiquement critiqué la politique
zéro zéro covid et d'ailleurs cette
message de l'ambassadeur de France voilà
a été soutenu par un ensemble de chinois
sur le réseau volibo donc enfin
quelqu'un parle de nous en quelque sorte
enfin quelqu'un parle de nous alors
justement les entreprises en Chine les
entreprises françaises en tout cas
Marianne elles ont aussi exprimé une
lassitude donc même chose face au covid
donc même lassitude qui aura suscité
cette enthousiasme on se demande si
effectivement la Chine va continuer va
pouvoir continuer à être l'usine du
monde bah effectivement parce que
notamment il me semble qu'il y a du
télétravail imposé
des tests PCR imposées enfin finalement
les entreprises françaises ne n'ont plus
en Chine ce terrain de croissance
qu'elles avaient trouvé et puis en plus
la Chine effectivement va s'orienter
pardon les occidentaux vont s'orienter
vers l'Inde
délocalise tous les pays c'est 2% pour
l'instant pour le moment mais de fait ça
va monter
bien ils prévoient en 25 en 2025 ils
vont diversifier en fait et de localiser
probablement donc là encore la Chine
franchement se tire une balle dans pied
d'un point de vue économique en tout cas
les dessinateurs oui je vais vous
montrer deux dessins un premier dessin
de Martine voltoring des Pays-Bas
iPhone rongé par le virus ça pourrait
être son titre mais voilà c'est une
traduction à la mode un peu surréaliste
de de la situation qui est très bien vu
la politique zéro covid l'iPhone et le
virus quand même qui qui sévit et puis
redo dessinateur français qui pose la
vraie question foxconnes la plus grosse
usine chinoise de fabrication d'iPhone
est en crise les ouvriers manifestent
contre les conditions de travail et puis
cette jeune fille qui répond mais on
aura quand même des promaxes à Noël
alors je savais pas ce que c'était que
des Promax c'est mon collègue qui m'a
dit que c'est le dernier modèle d'iPhone
voilà donc de la même façon qu'on on
peut pas boycotter le virus parce que
c'est compliqué mais peut-être qu'on
peut écouter peut-être la fin de l'usine
du monde en Chine on verra cela on coupe
du monde je sais que je n'ai pas un
plateau très inspiré mais enfin quand
même il reste 5 minutes donc elle est
qui commence sur la Coupe du monde
peut-être justement cette histoire de
brassard qui continue ce brassard One
Love de soutien en soutien la diversité
la FIFA l'a interdit les Allemands ont
bravé cette interdiction en imitant un
bâillement l'équipe d'Allemagne avant de
démarrer est-ce que les joueurs doivent
s'engager
pas
de réponse non
c'est difficile on pourrait faire une
émission je pense sur le Qatar et le
foot et donc c'est très difficile de
tout résumer même trois donc j'ai des
points de vue totalement
divergent j'ai envie de dire oui
effectivement je trouve que nos nos
joueurs et même notre président ne sont
pas très courageux vu les liens qui nous
lient au Qatar j'ai envie de dire en
même temps il faudrait qu'on soit
courageux vis-à-vis de bon nombre de
pays
ce que l'on n'est pas et j'ai envie de
dire le problème vient aussi de ce choix
de cette Coupe du Monde qui est à telle
période et on n'a pas dénoncé tout ce
que tout ce dont le Qatar finalement est
responsable dans le monde donc si vous
laissez c'est très compliqué à apprendre
la position je pense les footballeurs
français sont très gênés mais bon ok ils
sont décidés
et j'ai quand même et j'ai fini là
contrairement aux Allemands quand même
différente les Allemands je trouve que
les Allemands ont aussi des relations
économiques avec le Qatar et ce sont
plus
on laissait plus la mise de l'intérieur
est arrivé avec justement le brassard
dans les tribunes hein absolument ils
ont été plus courageux mais en tout cas
cette gêne caste tellement la magie du
Mondial et c'est en cela ce Mondial au
Qatar
restera parce qu'on peut tout le monde
pense à cette catastrophe écologique que
représente ce Mondial tout le monde
pense tout ce qui s'est passé en amont
au point de vue social et de fait ce qui
se passe dans ce Mondial ce qu'on est en
train de vivre maintenant ou alors que
les gens ils veulent pas les mondiaux
pour les Mondiaux préfet précédent était
plutôt passionnés machin on voit quand
même on attend les audiences ne baisse
pas les audiences souvent français
sur le Mondial c'est 5 milliards de
personnes au total on verra mais c'est
aussi un avertissement par rapport à ce
qui est encore plus une folie qui sont
quand même les Jeux olympiques d'hiver
en Arabie Saoudite alors voilà donc ce
serait là
il est peut-être temps à avant d'arrêter
la folie Candice de dessinateurs
je vais essayer de tous les montrer ont
un premier dessin de de Cambon donc des
sénateurs français sur justement la
séquence One Love il imagine un dialogue
entre le président de la FIFA et les mir
du Qatar c'est messieurs ils sont
obligés de se sauter dessus et de
s'embrasser après un but évidemment
c'est tout le paradoxe c'est assez
savoureux un autre dessin du dessinateur
shabbat dessinateur suisse pour le temps
qu'on ne présente plus justement sur le
boycott du du Mondial ben voilà il est
bien drôle ce dessin parce que il s'est
amusé à imaginer donc un match entre le
Brésil et l'Allemagne plus oser encore
que de s'attaquer à l'art mais voilà
d'envoyer la soupe sur un écran de foot
alors les supporters sont pas contents
mais c'est un avis peut-être au lanceur
de soupe et puis pour terminer ce dessin
en bonus que je j'aime beaucoup
particulièrement de Sanaga dessinateur
français c'est français qui ont choisi
de boycotter la Coupe du Monde et puis
cette dame qui dit à son mari je croyais
que tu ne t'intéressais pas au foot et
lui qui répond ça pourrait être marre
que d'ailleurs
ça pourrait être Marc et même il y a
même une forme de ressemblance j'avoue
ça aide donc c'est facile le boycott
hein
totalement oh non il a pas l'air il a
pas l'air de trop s'intéresser au foot
en temps normal bon en tout cas les
Bleus ont battu les Australiens vous le
savez demain à 17h il joue contre le
Danemark on va voir d'ailleurs c'est
cette histoire de brassard parce que les
Danois étaient plutôt assez engagés sur
ce brassard One Love merci à tous les
quatre d'avoir été avec nous merci à
vous tous de nous avoir suivis je vous
souhaite à tous un très bon weekend et
restez sur France 24